welcome to this video flama Savita I
only had one game against him which I
lost okay let's see what do we get Ben
only kind of thing or c4 course he can
do this no is taking okay I really want
that back and what is he doing Bishop e3
trying to keep the pawn no okay yeah 94
b 3 this kind of thing but it's not so
easy to get something substantial
against this very solid position here
without ever moving your C porn now we
move the beep on which is really unusual
weakening lots of things on the C file C
4 C 3 and C 2 yeah my general plan is um
what is he doing here we don't
understand anything I was also trying to
say my general plan is d 6b should be
someone this is very tempting yeah so
it's giving me the exchange yes okay
very often why it has some kind of
compensation from that maybe in this
case as well Saudi 61 to avoid nights is
7 business of Bishop c7 he cannot play
Bishop age 6 i'm covering this at the
moment
so this is always a little compensation
for wide my king position is a tad shaky
but it's nothing really i mean i have to
take the exchange it's it's not a not an
exchange sack that you can just decline
and say i don't want it it's really
something that you have to take okay but
what is he doing now c4 c5 okay i'm
going to get counter play here quickly
want to use my my own my rook smacked of
pieces if possible taking them okay is
going for last resort kind of moves hmm
don't really get it okay that one hmm I
didn't see that coming okay I can take
care i guess i would have wouldn't have
minded to return some of that some of
that material hmm so okay we could be 6a
i get i get it this is kind of tricky 94
i can just call 94 right 94 bishop d 893
SF is a is a horrible current and of
course so sometimes i really take a long
time to play those moves took ages
I'm a whoreo cup yeah it's just this is
quite a lot mmm or is it better to take
on g5 this would be an extra piece this
is also an extra piece so not a big
difference
hmm any way to avoid a passive movement
probably not but ok I can go to c5 and
after that everything is defended for
Bishop c4 Knight to c6 coming yeah but
that's not really really dangerous right
quite resigned yeah okay I don't think
that this exchange tech was going to be
good um in fact I'm questioning this a3
before business it looks kind of strange
because a long-term you really have to
answer questions on the sea fowl it's
it's not it's not looking so great maybe
it's something that it's not it's not
terrible yeah I mean maybe Queen d2 and
something then try to move this night
and play crazy for later this is this is
really not on I mean here he has to give
me the exchange almost it's it's really
i mean you can go here but this is also
very very nice i mean i have the the
center and the two bishops you have a
five coming where it's really great now
can rather give the exchange than d6
drug t1 he has some fearsome
compensation it's not like it's
completely a completely out of the
out-of-this-world here this this
especially nine txt six is a funny funny
possibility in fact he could have played
that right away it would have been
strong computer points that out well
that would have been very disappointing
yeah it's very difficult now a lot to
take as b7 hangs and if i take this is a
big big pimp sorry it's a big pin here
and that's it quite remarkable
you went here and lost a big temple jigs
and here and now i think it's it's
basically to later why the computer is
saying Queen a1 still with a with minus
one minus one this is always very very
suspicious if the comp is giving plus 1
minus 1 this kind of thing when one side
is a look up it looks very dangerous
what is it saying but should be 692
Queen 85 Queen f6 queen e 5 with a
slight advantage to black whatever that
means okay okay it's an exchange
probably i'm defending objectively but
blitz game hmm tricky stuff okay well
thanks for watching